uh i'm gonna go to the mansion because
this is all in the same conversation
here and then we'll go to uh some sports
maybe next
uh page
six if you want to go there
controversial
democratic
irs bank reporting proposal is likely
dead mansion says this is a washington
examiner's story mansion said on tuesday
that he spoke to president biden about
the proposal which envisioned banks
reporting all accounts inflows and
outflows of over ten thousand dollars to
the irs to crack down on tax fraud after
the meeting he noted it will probably
not be in the planned mansion said he
told biden the idea was screwed up and
that the president concurred oh wow okay
the first iteration of the proposal cast
at an even broader net and would have
targeted all inflows and outflows over
600 however that was met with fierce
opposition from the banking industry and
republicans on capitol hill republicans
believe the bank reporting requirements
violate privacy and would be
logistically challenged so there you go
so that's a dead deal nothing's going to
happen there we've already talked about
that but they're up but they're the ten
thousand dollar figures still running
around out there
uh who who is that going to annoy the
most
whose life is going to get tougher
because of that
americans banks that's what i'm saying
is it more banks or is it more americans
i mean how many people wire ten thousand
dollars every day all the time i think
it's more for the banks because they
have to then get it approved for it yeah
imagine the extra work
reporting it's more them it's not the
individual so the bank is the one that's
going to be against that i'd say they're
probably heavily against it said the
wall street and the the banking industry
were very against it as well right where
they are of course there are so there's
more work load on there now mansion says
the completeness pure overhead this next
story the reuters story is slightly
different mention says everyone in the
u.s
who has been blessed and prospered
should pay patriotic tax democratic
senator joe mentioned said on wednesday
that people in the united states who
have been blessed and prospered should
pay a patriotic tax of 15 percent if
they end up with a zero
which is kind of what you're saying
manchin said he supported everyone
paying their fair share and did not like
to target different people under this
measure billionaires who escape paying
taxes by earning small salaries and
borrowing off their assets would find
themselves paying taxes to the federal
government at a fixed rate fine you're
okay with that i'd like this too
honestly it's a form of a flat tax it's
a good way because especially if if with
the current tax codes kind of how
they'll find a loophole either way
anyways and and this would then kind of
limit that and i mean at 15
it's i think it's fair this is on what
though this is on gains he's saying
right is the or is this on no no no no
right now what's being talked about with
this 1.7 trillion which is the new price
tag does your the price tag changes
every day is uh people who make 10
million or more
this 15 percent he's talking about is 10
million right now they're talking about
a three percent surcharge i saw that one
but that's different than that that's
different than this yeah this is cleaner
what mansion is proposing is cleaner so
so walk me through what this looks like
it's pretty simple you pay tax is it on
april 15th on what though on your income
on the income so if i so if the person
makes no this is this i don't think
that's what makes an income because
because the thing that rich people or
technically a lot of these billionaires
do is they have a lot of debt borrowed
up against their holdings
to do the write-offs yes that way
because because debt if you're if your
stock is appreciating by six percent
your debt is a three percent i don't
think that's a good idea then why not be
because accounting purposes so now you
have to track the debt people are
taking against their income how do you
do that you just close the loopholes
yeah it's not it's not bad but you're
taking away the deductions but a part of
that
is is isn't a part of this link to
capital gains so if i'm making so again
for me it would be
how do you measure to tax 15 on what the
what if the company had a bad year what
if what if the income was i mean because
if you're making income you're going to
pay the tax taxes on ordinary income so
this the way they're awarding this the
patriotic tax i kind of want to know a
little bit more on what he means by that
you know because i don't think it's just
on your income i get an income we
already have ordinary income tax but you
would never be able to you you would
have to close the loopholes and then
what would the cpas do you would have to
fire all lobbyists who still who's the
most against getting rid of lobbyists by
the way the left or the right who
doesn't want lobbyists the right well
probably i don't think they're both
false no they're both i mean god they
both spend like drunk sailors both
parties some of the numbers you see like
on on
pharmaceutical companies on what they do
with lobbyists national association of
realtors yeah
how about the fact that they associate
the word or attach the word patriotic
with wanting to pay more taxes right is
it does that correlate does that go it
does it does you should want to pay your
fair share
if if if you're in a country and you
have freedom and you're able to be
prosperous then it shouldn't bother you
to pay your fair share by force or by
choice
no just by simple laws
just by simplifying the tax code
then then then you got to simplify it
all across the board though no okay yeah
so let's just simplify it across that
well we're paying taxes right to do some
what what are our taxes supposed to pay
for why can't why can't our taxes go
towards simplifying the tax code i don't
i don't mind that but i like what elon
musk said the challenge for me is
who is managing the money i'm paying
taxes for like is that money going to go
to people in the government that are
going to manage that money because they
have no clue what the hell they're doing
or is that money going to go to the
private sector at least they know what
to do with that money obama admitted it
he said that you know his shovel ready
infrastructure plan did a whole bunch of
nothing for the economy
and and we're talking about another
infrastructure plan that's going to be
doled out by bureaucrats two unionized
workers that's what i'm saying it's it
it it accomplishes nothing so you're
right makes a point it almost makes a
point a very good point so
what's the what's the one guy's name uh
reich uh uh uh uh rich strike i don't
know if it's richard
the the
what's his name tyler rob robert robert
robert robert he always posts stuff on
twitter right and then he says uh
you know uh people forget that how much
of a public uh uh money ilan got to help
them out with uh you know tesla or all
these other things right great the
grants that they got the billions of
dollars of grants well but the money is
going to
private sector yeah and people on the
private sector know what to do with that
money better than people in the public i
remember even elon went back at him and
said well we paid off all interest years
before plus interest so he paid off
early with all the interest they would
have paid if they extended the whole
time and he's like well look at ge they
still have billions they have the same
as gm yeah but aig paid it back 183 plus
years 21 billion so i mean maybe they've
taken it out of the textbooks already so
children if you're listening
the new deal the real part of the new
deal that fdr implemented was done with
pr public money through the private
sector that's why we've got the hoover
dam that's why that's why so much was
accomplished because it was public money
but then it was deployed to the private
sector so you're not waiting smart to do
that you're not wasting the money it's
combining the marriage that's smart to
do that yeah that's because they're
going to allocate the money and not use
it more efficiently all those things
competitively privates accountable
public is i mean
not
exactly yeah especially when you talk
about a huge infrastructure bill like
are we going to see new airports are the
freeways going to be fixed exactly yeah
if they said well 32 million 32 billion
is going to go to this airport it's
going to be done by this state this is
going to go for an intercoastal highway
we're going to improve the 95 we're
going to allocate this much from this
stretch to this stretch if you're giving
specifics and when yeah it's like okay
maybe that could be worth it but if i
mean you know most americans probably
think that toll roads are really worth
it
because they're in better shape
and you can get through faster right
right as opposed to taking this lane all
that like yeah nobody questions paying
for the express lane how much weight
like look you just say five minutes it's
five minutes worth of ten bucks five
bucks yeah go do it you don't want it
don't do it it's a choice i like that so
but but it's also because the other
infrastructure that's available is
falling apart yeah so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye-bye
[Music]